今天要聊的這個案例，我覺得非常出乎意料。你可能沒想到，在電動車的能源效率上，印度製造商竟然超越了特斯拉和比亞迪這些全球巨頭。
喔？這就有點意思了。特斯拉和比亞迪在電動車領域可是龍頭啊，印度公司怎麼可能在效率上勝過他們？這不是跟我們一般認知的常理不太一樣嗎？
就是這種「與一般想法不同」的地方才讓我特別注意。國際清潔交通委員會（ICCT）公布的全球電動車電池效率排名顯示，印度的塔塔汽車平均每公里消耗 106 瓦時，位居第一。
等等，106 瓦時每公里？這個數字代表什麼？跟特斯拉比呢？
他們的數據顯示，特斯拉和比亞迪分別排在第三和第四。而印度的另一家公司 Mahindra，也以 113 瓦時每公里緊隨其後。這個排名評估了全球 22 家最大的電動車公司。
這樣說來，印度公司確實表現不錯。但能源效率好，不代表全部都好啊。他們會不會是在其他地方犧牲了什麼，例如續航里程或者充電速度？這模式能撐得久嗎？成本划算嗎？
你這個問題問得很好。原文裡確實有提到，塔塔汽車在充電速度上排名墊底，續航里程也倒數第六。所以，他們並不是全面領先，而是專注在能源效率這個點上做到極致。
這樣就說得通了。等於是把所有資源集中火力在單一優勢上。那他們具體是怎麼做到的？難道只是把電池做得更小、車身更輕嗎？
其實原文提到，印度政府在燃油和排放標準上制定了非常「積極且雄心勃勃」的目標。ICCT 的印度區總經理 Amit Bhatt 就說，這對推動電動車發展扮演了關鍵角色。
所以不只是車廠單方面的努力，還有政策的推波助瀾。這些嚴格的法規迫使他們必須在能源效率上找到突破口，這樣才符合政府的電動車推廣目標，對吧？
對，印度政府的目標是到 2030 年，30% 的乘用車都要電動化。這不僅是為了減排，也是為了減少石油進口、強化能源安全。在這樣的環境下，車廠就必須把「節能」變成核心競爭力。
這樣聽起來，對於我們這些中小企業來說，其實也很有啟發。我們可能沒有大公司的資金和規模去搞全面競爭，但可以選擇一個點，深耕下去。
沒錯。如果我是個小型家電製造商，我可能不會去跟大品牌比功能多寡，而是專注在某個特定功能上，例如「最低耗能的冰箱」或者「最安靜的洗衣機」，然後把這個點做到最好。
嗯，有點像是差異化競爭，但更聚焦。把利基市場做到極致。那對於一般上班族來說，這個概念能用得上嗎？
我覺得可以。比如說，你在公司負責某個專案，可能有很多面向要做。但你可以思考，這個專案最核心、最有價值的一個環節是什麼？把精力集中在那裡，做到你部門甚至全公司都無人能及。
專注在一個關鍵的「能源效率點」上，這樣即使在其他方面沒有那麼突出，也能創造出不可替代的價值。這好像也提醒了我們，有時候放手一些不必要的競爭，反而能走得更遠。